- During Created Equal,
not, not this project,
the Created Equal.
We were up in San-hold your thought.
- [Host] Yep.
- So as I was in San Francisco with,
one of my assistants
working on Created Equal,
and I just, I wanted to do a
portrait of the Hells Angels.
And you can't just like call them up,
I'm some stranger from L.A.
You just have to show up.
So nine in the morning,
I went to the clubhouse in Oakland
for the Hells Angels.
Knocked on their door,
nobody answered.
Knocked on the door louder,
knocked on the door a third time,
the fuck do you want?(laughs)
It's this is biker shows up
and he wants to kill me
because I woke him up.
And most people would be like,
well you don't wanna do that.
But no, I do that.
I do that.
But I also know how to
think on my feet really,
really well.
Better than, that's one of the
things I've learned is like,
no I'll figure shit out.
I don't know what I'm gonna figure out.
I don't even know what I'm
gonna have to figure out,
but whatever it is, I'll figure it out.
- Do you bring people
with you when you do this
or do you do it alone?
- I do, like I'll have
an assistant driving,
but I don't wanna him involved.
I'm protecting him from getting hurt.
- [Host] Right?
- So he's off two blocks down the street.
- [Host] And you are unarmed?
- I never carry any of that.
I've never shot a gun.
- [Host] No?
- I'm not into that.
But people always say
you should and all that.
- Well , it's hairy because...
- I'm six, four and I can
kind of take care of myself
and even a biker, Hell's Angels.
I mean, with, with, with a
gun and a bat and a chain,
you could probably do some damage.
But I have a knack for, what's the word?
Diffusing?
- [Host] Right.
- I mean, whatever.
If somebody's got something
that they're threatening with,
I have a way of showing them
that, look, I'm not a threat.
I'm not here to hurt anybody.
- [Host] Right.
Here's what I'm doing.
Like with the pedophiles yesterday,
nobody said no to me,
because I presented to
him a way, like, look,
I'm just looking to hear your story.
I'm not here to make
you look like a bad guy.
I'm not here to do anything to you.
I'm not here to do anything other than
hear your side of the story.
And they can, I think they,
I think people can sense when
somebody's up to no good.
Or up, or there's
something shady going on.
And I don't do anything shady.
Like I don't, I'm not a liar.
I don't, I don't do things to people that,
that I have to, like, I go to bed tonight
with a clear conscience
every day of my life.
And that's super important to me.
Because like, I'm not tricking
anybody into anything.
I'm not scamming anybody.
I'm not pulling anything,
I'm not pulling anything.
I'm just telling you what I do.
If you're interested, that's cool.
And if you're not, that's cool too.
- [Host] Yeah. You're an open book.
- I'm an open book and I'm
not here to play anybody.
I'm not here to scam anybody.
So that's, that's super important.
And I think people can sense that.
And if you're, if you're just
coming at people with like,
here's what I'm doing.
I think you're interesting.
I'd love to talk to you.
Love to hear your story.
People love to tell their stories.
Like, I mean, one of the
things I find interesting on
my channel is, a lot of
these people have confessed
to like even murders and crazy things.
There's a few people that
are confessed to murders
or things close to it.
Things that don't have a
statute of limitations on them.
So it's like, why, why the
hell would you say that?
I'll tell, I'll say to them
after the interview, like why,
why the hell would you say that?
They're like meh. I'm
not worried about it.
So you want me to put this
on, I can put it on YouTube.
You sure?
They go yeah, like go ahead.
(ominous music plays)